patience
patience with myself i bet you when i
have kids i'm going to be like i didn't
even know what patience was before that
haley bieber is getting candid about
when she plans to have kids with her
husband justin i'm excited the 25 year
old model graces the cover of wsj
magazine's spring women's fashion issue
and inside she's an open book about her
life specifically when she and her hubby
plan to expand their family haley tells
the mag in part quote everybody always
assumes it's first comes love then comes
marriage then comes the baby well what
about all the things i want to
accomplish in my business she also says
initially it was ingrained in her mind
to have kids immediately after getting
married but she had a change of heart
quote i turned 25 and i'm like i'm still
super super young
so when does the couple think they'll be
ready haley says i think ideally in the
next couple of years we would try but
there's a reason they call it try right
you don't know how long that process is
ever going to take definitely no kids
this year that would be a little bit
hectic i think given attention for 2021
hopefully
we squish out a nugget as for justin's
perspective on the whole kids thing well
he opened up in his documentary last
year justin bieber our world in 2021
the end of 2021 we we start trying okay
maybe
we shall see
and back in 2020 the ghost singer
revealed to ellen degeneres how many
kids he wants uh
i think it's up to haley because it's
her body when it comes to the couple's
nearly four year long marriage haley
tells the mag how surprisingly normal
things are despite being in the
limelight the new york native says
they're just regular people quote i
think given the magnitude of justin's
career he's a very normal person and i
don't think that always happens what do
you love about justin he's really funny
we have a good time together
he's just really sweet he's a good kid
he's a good part and
i love him and as for what married life
has taught haley she says it's an
exercise in patients patience with
myself
patients with my partner
patients
with
my dog patients just in every aspect of
the word